for his towering talents for his  services to the Academy the industry and  the American people for laughter on a  unique level and for one of the  outstanding achievements in human  relations in anyone's memory the UNICEF  film assignment children the Academy's  honorary award to Danny Kaye  there are many unsung heroes behind this  award have the very nice things that  were said I believe the thing that  pleases me most is the assignment we got  to do a documentary film for UNICEF  through the medium of the motion picture  we can make the world better understand  the problem of the world's children I  think perhaps we'll be on our way to  making the world understand itself a  little better I'm grateful and proud  indeed to be a part of a tremendous  industry that has it within its power to  accomplish this and I'm grateful indeed  to be one of its servants thank you very  much